alex mills getting the start
forward three a 455 era but has been
good as a starter the sinker the change
up the big slow curve ball and the
slider has been a factor as well otto
has home runs in five straight games and
he has seven home runs vato's last seven
hits have all been home runs
he swings and he puts a charge into it
right center field goodbye
voto has done it
a new reds record
home runs in six consecutive games folks
it's just not that easy i just can't
believe that alec mills would even give
him a pitch like that to hit i am
stunned thinking that mills could sneak
that fastball
by joey botto because it's just not
going to happen
that was a rocket and i tell you what
that pitch was middle in
and vato did not miss it he crushed it
431 feet from home plate into the right
center field bleachers at 111 miles an
hour off his back two nothing reds on
vato's eighth home run in his last six
games red starter luis castillo to a two
nothing advantage castillo owns a
1.71 era going back to june the first
that is the best not just in the
national league but in all of major
league baseball javier baez steps in two
outs and a man at second the one-two
swinging to miss he strikes out there
chasing a
slider down and away baez strikes out
the inning is over and castillo able to
work around the two singles to start
this first reds lead it two to nothing
at the end of one two nothing red second
inning a man at first jonathan india
steps in
ground ball in a second scooped up by
bodhi he throws out india
one second baseman bounces out to
another reds don't score we go to the
bottom of the second inning cincinnati
two cubs nothing castillo seems to have
more consistent location when he's in a
little bit quicker rhythm when he just
gets the ball gets the sign and cuts it
loose
castillo gets his second strikeout of
the day he is so seemingly effortless it
looks so fluid so easy
swinging at a miss took care of him with
a heater and a one two three inning for
luis castillo three of them in the book
here wrigley field the reds two cubs
nothing patrick wisdom will try to get
something going for the cubs here on the
bottom of the fourth inning against luis
castillo
fly ball deep left center field this is
back toward the wall it's got a chance
gone
patrick wisdom with a home run to lift
the cubs trail 2-1 his 16th of the year
now wisdom got a breaking ball out over
the plate and he hammers this ball he
might have caught it just a little off
the end of the bat
with the wind blowing in from right
really didn't help it much but it makes
about the second row in the bleachers
and wisdom once again he has just showed
incredible power and has just really
played some good quality baseball for
the cubs since getting called up red's
pitcher luis castillo an infield hit his
first time up bats leading off the reds
fifth castillo very similar to his last
hit
barehand has no play and luis castillo
has two infield hits and we've been
taking all this time talking about votto
this is the guy that's swinging the bat
he's got that topper down right on top
of the plate
this is castillo's third career two-hit
game here's contreras now with two outs
and a man at first
maybe wilson runs into one and gives the
cubs a lead
[Applause]
i think he heard you
wow and no doubter 464
feet this ball absolutely obliterated
look at this powerful swing from wilson
contreras leverage against that front
side head right on it and wilson i mean
he hits this ball an absolute ton
[Applause]
of bargain after contreras took a little
time to admire that one so watch wilson
after he hits it
oh yeah i mean
it's it's interesting castillo spun
around and immediately looked at
controls to see
whether he was kind of running or not i
mean in the modern game
that's pretty subtle
there there's no huge bad flip so the
cubs lead by a run two on nobody out and
the 01 pitch coming in a quinn
naked went to wisdom hits the bag and
loses the ball they do get the force at
first but that's all farmer to third
votto up to second one out wow i'm not
really sure that that's an out the reds
may challenge this and i think they're
going to win it take a look i think he
started his move back towards the bag a
bit early
that left foot is not on the back
that falls all over the place that's
going to be nick when at first base say
so the fifth error of the year for
wisdom his first outside of third base
and that loads the bases up for tucker
barnhart
barnhart
grounds it up the middle and through
vatos scores naked given the green light
he scores and the reds ahead
tucker barnhart a two-run base knock 4-3
cincinnati castillo ready to step in
runners lead at every station
back to the mound mills comes home they
get one there
double play the old one two three twin
killing
ends the inning nobody out reds with a
one run lead 4-3 top of seven
kyle farmer awaits
and swung on fair ball down the right
field line that it barely kicked up the
chalk farmers got a base hit he's going
for two to throw in by hayward not in
time
and the throw gets away now and jesse
wicker is going to score from third
so kyle farmer
clears the bases on an opposite field
double right inside the first baseline
and a bad relay operation by javier baez
allows the
second run to score as winker comes
around and the reds have stretched their
lead to three man and third one out
aquino
to left center ortega sliding grab tag
at third
farmers scores aquino gets the job done
a 7-3 reds lead so one down and now
happened
towards left field
well that's got to feel good
he has been struggling here as of late
and not getting the same playing time
that he's been accustomed to and
for him to launch one that's a good
thing for him henry staring in for the
sign
swing and a miss hembree strikes him out
and the reds claim the series another
win
over the cubs